MALE SPEAKER: Everyone, please
welcome Sharon Salzberg.
SHARON SALZBERG: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
It's a great delight to be here.
My most current sublet
in New York City
is just a few blocks away, so
I feel like we're neighbors.
And I love just being
able to walk to a place.
Plus, the meditation program
here sounds just fabulous,
and I'm so happy
to hear about it.
It's really funny
for me sitting here.
I'm looking at what you're
looking at on the screen.
And I'm reading the blurb,
"Anyone who has a job
will find treasures here."
Daniel Goleman, author of
"Emotional Intelligence."
Because Dan actually brought
me to my very first meditation
retreat in India
in January of 1971.
I had heard him give a talk at
a yoga conference in New Delhi.
I had gone to India as part of
an independent study program
through the university
I was attending.
And I really wanted to
learn how to meditate.
And I wanted what
seemed to me to be
very practical, pragmatic,
direct instruction.
I didn't want something very
overly philosophical or deeply
embedded in a kind of traditions
so that I had to, in some way,
adopt the dogma or the belief
system of the tradition.
So I kind of couldn't
find that right away.
And I wandered around India.
And I went to this
international yoga conference,
which was quite a dispiriting
affair, the low point of which
was when these yogis and
swamis were up on the stage
pushing and shoving against each
other to try to grab the mic
and speak.
And I thought, oh, god.
I'll never find a teacher here.
And then Dan-- at the time, he
was a graduate student studying
meditation and psychology.
And he delivered a
paper, at the end
of which he mentioned
that he was on his way
to this town called
[? Belgaum ?] in India,
where he was going to do this
intensive 10-day meditation
retreat which was very kind
of direct, and pragmatic,
and practical.
And I followed after him,
as did probably close to 100
of us attending that conference,
went to that meditation
retreat.
So it's very funny,
all these years
later, for me just to be sitting
here and seeing his name.
Because of course, I owe him a
tremendous debt of gratitude.
And I was also going to tell a
story about Dan Harris, who's
a friend of mine.
So those of you who go to
his talk tomorrow, please
bring this up in some fashion.
You don't have to tell
him I told you to.
Dan, as many people who
embark on meditation,
who have an interest
in learning meditation,
tended to really appreciate
qualities like mindfulness,
presence, the
clarity it can bring,
the kind of perspective
it can bring,
the balance it could bring.
And he had a different
kind of response
to terms like lovingkindness
or compassion.
And this was a lot
of what I wanted
to begin with anyway-- how there
are two things that I find kind
of provocative here, in terms
of approaching qualities
like lovingkindness
and compassion
as things that are trainable
and as things that are powerful.
We tend to think,
what do you mean,
"train" a quality
like compassion?
That's awfully cold
or mechanistic.
It's like, I'm going
to a love training.
You know?
It's just too bizarre.
Whereas in the East,
in eastern psychology,
absolutely, a quality like
lovingkindness or compassion
is felt to be trainable.
Because it's felt that these
are emergent properties
of how we pay attention.
And so we know absolutely
attention can be trainable.
And that, in fact, is
what meditation is.
And so as a consequence,
we can actually
train in something like
lovingkindness or compassion.
And it's felt that these things
aren't weak, or sentimental,
or kind of gooey.
Those are a force.
Those qualities of love, or
lovingkindness, and compassion
are powerful.
So that's a challenge
for most of us.
It was certainly a
challenge for Dan.
So the first book I ever wrote
was called "Lovingkindness."
And Dan told me that he used
to read it in the New York City
subway.
And he was so
embarrassed to be seen
reading a book called
"Lovingkindness" that he would
cleverly place his
fingers over the title,
so nobody could see
what he was reading.
And then he actually--
this is in his book.
He was doing the
practice, which,
of course, is a very
different thing than standing
back and critiquing
the practice.
He was actually
doing the practice,
and he had a very
powerful experience.
And so when his
book came out, he
posted a lovingkindness
meditation on abc.com.
So you can imagine how happy
I was, all these years later,
to see that.
And he was on "HuffPost
Live" being interviewed.
And they asked certain people
to do some short videos
that he would be presented
with during his interview,
and he would respond.
So they asked me to do a video.
And for some reason, I thought
it was kind of like a roast.
Everyone else was just, like,
straightforward and praising,
and I was roasty.
[LAUGHTER]
And so I told that story.
And I said, oh, imagine
how happy I was, Dan,
to see when you posted a
lovingkindness meditation
on ABC News.
And so they showed him
this, and he laughed.
And he said, it is the most
annoying meditation possible.
And it works.
He said, every
single day, my wife
is thankful that I'm much
less of a jerk, which
is the way he talks.
So you might just bring it
up tomorrow, those of you.
What do you think of
lovingkindness meditation, Dan?
Or what about that
compassion thing?
So those I find are
actually the two kind
of major challenges
people present.
How can this be trainable?
That's bizarre.
And I don't know
about that love thing.
It's so squishy.
That means you
lose common sense.
You lose discernment.
You lose an ability
to have an edge.
You lose ambition or clarity.
You just lose, lose, lose.
And so that's really what
we tend to emphasize.
None of that is actually true.
Attention is trainable.
Therefore, these
qualities will emerge.
The first question is, how
are we paying attention?
Are we fragmented?
Are we all over the place?
Are we actually present?
In this society, where
we tend to engage in what
Linda Stone called "continuous
partial attention"--
which is kind of all over
the place all of the time.
Just to gather our attention
and our energy and to be there,
to connect, to listen
is a powerful thing.
It's a powerful gift
for one another.
I have a friend who, every
time we go out to dinner
or we do something
together, we ritualistically
tweet at the beginning.
Having dinner with so-and-so.
Having dinner with
@SharonSalzberg.
And somebody once
wrote and said,
do you ever talk to each other?
Or do you just sit there?
And a lot of time, we do
actually talk to each other.
But a lot of times, don't
we-- or we wish we could.
We're not really listening.
We're not really present.
And so the first step
in training attention
towards that quality
of, say, compassion
is gathering our attention.
And it's arriving, it's being
unified, it's being present.
And then the question
arises-- what
do we tend to pay attention to?
Let's say you're
the kind of person
who, at the end of the day,
you're looking back at your day
at work.
And you pretty
well only remember
the things you did
wrong, and the mistakes
you made, and where you
didn't really show up,
and what you could have
done more skillfully,
let's just say, so much so that
your whole sense of who you are
and all that you
will ever be just
collapses around that
really stupid thing
you said at lunch at a meeting.
The challenge, or the
training in attention,
is to not deny that or
pretend it didn't happen,
but to get bigger in our
perspective, in our connection.
Because it's not the
only thing that happened.
It's not all that we are.
So it's almost as though
one is asking oneself,
anything else happen today?
Or any good?
And even when we make
a mistake, recognizing
there's a kind of
capacity to begin again,
which doesn't deny that we
have something to learn,
or we need to make amends, or
we need to rectify something.
But we don't have
to be stuck there.
We can have a different
perception of who we are
and what we're capable of.
So we stretch beyond that
kind of collapse or fixation
of attention.
And a very interesting question
is, who do we pay attention to?
Who do we objectify?
Who becomes the "other" for us?
Perhaps through fear,
perhaps through bias.
And a lot of times just
through indifference.
Who doesn't count?
Who doesn't matter?
Who do we look through?
Somebody plays a
role in our lives,
and for all we recognize this is
a living, breathing human being
who wants to be
happy just as we do,
they might as well be
a piece of furniture.
It's kind of shocking when
you look at yourself--
you know, me, too--
going throughout a day,
and how many times that happens.
So who counts?
Who matters?
It makes me think of--
I go to Washington, DC
a fair amount to teach.
And years ago,
the facility, when
I was teaching a day-long
workshop, the facility
they rented was this
elementary school.
It's since been torn down,
so we use something else.
But it was this
great place, in part
because that school had
its own rules of kindness.
And so whenever we'd
take a break from sitting
or we would do
walking meditation,
the rules of kindness were
all over the corridors
on these big pieces of paper.
And we'd just stand
there and read them,
because they were so cool.
They said things like, don't
hurt anyone on the inside
or on the outside.
But my very, very
favorite rule of kindness
was, everybody gets to play.
Everybody gets to play.
Not, everybody is
my best friend,
and I'm going to take
them home with me,
but everybody gets to play.
That's kind of the sensibility
when we actually pay attention
to others rather
than look through.
We may not like somebody.
We may not approve of them.
We certainly may not
give them all our money
or take them home--
or the thing I always
say in New York, which
only makes here-- you never
give away your rent-controlled
apartment, ever.
Right?
But you can have
that inner sense
of everybody's kind of
innate dignity and worth.
And just include
rather than exclude.
So who do we pay attention to?
Who do we ignore?
Who do we discount?
And the nature of the specific
training around lovingkindness
or compassion-- and we'll
talk about the distinction
between the two in a
minute-- is sometimes
what I call a stretch.
It's seeing, oh, I'm used to
paying attention in this way,
I'm used to thanking
these five people
and ignoring everybody else.
I'm used to fixating
on my faults
and not the potential within me.
And we stretch.
We realize, OK, I have a certain
perhaps limited, habitual way
of viewing myself and others.
And I'm going to see
what it's like when
I go beyond that particular
narrow constraint.
Not moving from a true place
to a false or phony place,
but moving from a true place to
another true place, which maybe
gets a lot less air
time, usually, from us.
So we kind of play.
It's a very playful practice
where you walk, maybe,
into that grocery
store, and instead
of looking through the
clerk, you look at them.
And you think, may you be happy.
May you be peaceful.
May you have a good day.
May things work out for you,
whatever your struggles may be.
So it's that kind of play
in that particular practice.
And then we see what happens.
So there are actually
four qualities
that are usually talked
about together, in a bundle.
And sometimes, just in
casual conversation,
there are terms
used synonymously,
but they actually have
slightly different flavors.
And they work together
in different ways.
So the first is
lovingkindness itself.
And that's a weird word.
Isn't it?
Because you wouldn't necessarily
be, say, sitting in a coffee
shop somewhere and hear the
next table's conversation
include the word,
"lovingkindness."
And so my concern about that is
that it might make the quality
itself seem kind of arcane, and
removed from day-to-day life,
and precious in the
negative sense of the word.
It's a translation of a word
from the Buddhist tradition.
There's another word in
the Jewish tradition.
Both are translated
as "lovingkindness."
Sometimes it's translated
instead as "love,"
which is extremely
complicated, of course,
because we use that word to
mean so many different things.
Sometimes we say "love,"
and it really frankly
is a medium of exchange.
Like, I will love
you as long as.
Or I will love myself as long
as I never make a mistake.
So that isn't
going to last long.
And we know how fragile,
how breakable that state is.
It literally means
"friendship" in translation
from the Buddhist tradition.
But I think the best
way of understanding
it is a profound sense of
connection-- not liking, not
approving, but connection.
That our lives are
inextricably interwoven,
that we are living in an
interdependent universe, which
isn't always so nice, you know?
But it's true.
What happens over there isn't
going to nicely stay over
there, and we're going to
be protected forevermore.
It's going to ripple
out over here.
And what we do, it matters.
And it ripples out in all
these other directions.
It's just the nature of things.
Like sometimes, when I go into
a company or place of work
and teach, one of the
reflections I ask people to do
is, how many other people
need to do their jobs well
for you to be able
to do your job well?
Because we do get awfully
kind of siloed and isolated.
And we forget we actually
live in this interconnected
universe, that that's
how things are.
And that's very much the
sense of lovingkindness.
It's like a bone-deep
appreciation
of all the kinds of connection
that is real for us--
that our lives have something
to do with one another.
And then the second
quality is compassion,
which is talked about as
a movement of the heart.
It's a recognition either
of pain or of vulnerability.
We may not all be experiencing
equal challenges in life,
for sure.
We just don't.
But we do share a kind of
inherent vulnerability.
Because life's so insecure.
It's mutable.
It's moving.
It's changing all of the time.
And we can care for one
another in those ways.
It's a way of-- not giving
in, and not being weak,
and not being
foolish, but of kind
of responding from
a heart-felt place.
And it begins-- they both begin,
actually-- with ourselves.
So one of the exercises
we sometimes say
is when you-- maybe we'll
do this as the meditation.
When you undertake
anything, there
is the necessity to
continually begin again.
The way I put it these
days is, nothing in life
is a straight shot.
We go forward.
We fall down.
We have to get up or
let others help us up.
We go forward again.
We make a mistake.
We have to realize that,
OK, I'm going to start over.
We lose sight of our
aspiration, maybe
our tremendous aspiration.
We just forget about it.
We have to begin again.
We lose touch with our values.
We are reminded, or we remember.
We have to begin again.
We're constantly recovering.
We're repairing.
We're starting over.
And the question is how to
do that most skillfully.
And this is one of
those places where
there's a kind of controversy.
Because people say, well, that
self-compassion thing-- that's
just being lazy.
You know, what do you
mean, forgive yourself
and start over?
Then you'll just blow
it off the next time.
And somebody said
that to me, actually,
in a class in New York.
I don't believe that.
Because then I'll
just say, hey, I'll
make another mistake in two
minutes, who cares, you know?
I'll start again.
But think about it.
What happens when
you make a mistake
or you have to
start over, and you
spend 15 hours in this
tirade against yourself,
and you're just miserable,
and you feel like you're
an awful person, and
you have no capacity
to change or to do
things differently?
And you just go down.
We end up exhausted.
It takes a long time.
We end up demoralized.
We don't have the kind of
energy to begin again well.
Studies seem to show-- there
are all kinds of performance
studies of all kinds that show
that harshness, being motivated
by fear-- really intense
fear, self-criticism--
will help you spike your
performance briefly.
And then you crash.
And that to have a sustained
effort to get something done,
to do it well, to really put
yourself out there in some way,
we seem to need
another kind of skill
in terms of actually what
is true about the way things
evolve.
We're always beginning
again, and having to repair
and having to recover, and kind
of adjust, and find balance,
and things like that.
And so that's the
role of compassion.
It doesn't mean you don't care.
It doesn't mean you're
kind of sickly sweet.
overly sentimental.
It's just seeing, oh, this kind
of caring-- applied to myself,
applied to others-- is actually
the most effective, efficient
way to have a life.
And that's where it
begins, is with ourselves.
To have that kind of resonance,
like, ooh, that hurts-- not,
I'm bad, I'm terrible, I'm
awful, I'm stupid-- but ooh,
that really hurts gives us
a very different approach
in which to go on,
and then relate
to ourselves in all kinds
of different situations,
and relate to others.
So then the third quality--
I like talking about,
because it's kind
of quirky for us.
And that's a quality called
sympathetic joy, which
means having happiness for the
happiness of others instead
of, when we witness someone's
success or good fortune, kind
of dying inside-- you know,
falling sway to that voice
that so often arises inside
our heads that goes, ooh,
I wish you didn't have so
much going for you right now.
Like, you don't have
to lose everything,
but if the light
could just dim a bit,
I would feel a lot better.
So this doesn't mean that you
lose all competitive edge,
and that you lose ambition,
and that you can't go for it.
You can go for it.
But some of the ways that we
suffer-- it's like nothing's
ever enough.
We don't feel in touch
with what we have.
We only feel
consumed with what we
don't have-- and so this
kind of endless cycle
of dissatisfaction.
Sometimes what
someone accomplishes
feels like it's
been taken directly
from us, as though
happiness were a limited
commodity in this world, and
the more someone else has,
the less there's
going to be for us.
But it's not like that.
I have a retreat center
I cofounded, the Insight
Meditation Society in
Barre, Massachusetts.
And I teach there every
winter a seven-day intensive
lovingkindness retreat.
And I was giving a talk one
night on sympathetic joy.
And I just used this example.
It just came up in my head.
I said, it's like
you're in New York.
And it's Sunday.
And you buy the
"New York Times,"
and you open up to the
Book Review section.
And you look at the
Best Seller list.
And you see that your
friend's book has gotten on
the "New York Times"
Best Seller list.
And you think, that's a pity.
It should have been my book.
And then there's
kind of the thought,
it would have been my book,
except they stole it from me--
these people, these
so-called friends.
It's like, the "New
York Times" had just
typed out half the
title of my book,
and somehow, you subverted it,
and you grabbed it from me.
It's not a logical feeling.
Because of course,
it's not like that.
But it feels as though
it were just like that.
So I gave this talk.
And by sheer coincidence,
I had three friends
sitting in the room, sitting
the retreat, each of whom
had had a book on the "New
York Times" Best Seller list.
And so each one of them came up
to me after the talk and said,
is that how you felt when you
saw my book on the "New York
Times" Best Seller list?
And I said, no.
[LAUGHS] Not at all.
Never, never.
But we can challenge
that feeling as well--
that sense of envy or jealousy.
Is happiness so limited?
Do we really have nothing?
Or do we not appreciate
and notice what we do have?
Did they really take
it away from me?
Do I want them to only
suffer and suffer?
Maybe not.
And so there are ways
that we kind of stretch
our assumptions and our
withholding, and so on.
And then the last quality
is known as equanimity.
And that means wisdom.
Equanimity is a weird word, too.
When I was first sitting
my first retreat in India,
the teacher was this
man named SN Goenka.
And he kept saying,
be equanimous.
Be equanimous.
And those of us sitting
the retreat would whisper
to each other, is that a word?
I never heard that word.
Equanimity does not
mean indifference,
or coldness, or callousness.
It means the balance
born of wisdom.
It's perspective.
Like, in compassion,
I will do everything
I can to try to make
your situation better,
and I'm not in control
of this universe.
I can't make it so.
Or things can take time.
I don't always see the immediate
result that I'm looking for.
Maybe I'm laying the groundwork.
Maybe I'm planting seeds.
There's change in this universe.
Nothing is fixed.
Nothing is static.
I will do everything,
and I also need
to let go of some kind of
need for things to work out
exactly the way I need them
or I think I need them to,
on my timetable,
and on my agenda.
So these four-- lovingkindness,
compassion, sympathetic joy,
and equanimity--
actually work together,
which is why, in compassion, you
don't really lose intelligence.
You don't lose power.
You don't lose strength.
Because it's got this balance.
It's got the balance of wisdom.
It's got the balance
of equanimity.
You don't go down,
because you're also
looking at joy and
sympathetic joy, right?
And you don't get giddy and
kind of superficial, frivolous,
because you're also looking
at pain with compassion.
And so together, they
make up a bundle.
What I'd like to
do is actually have
us sit together a little bit.
And then we'll just
open up for questions.
And have fun.
So I thought,
actually, we could do
that very foundational exercise
of awareness or mindfulness
of the breath, but
with this emphasis.
OK?
So if you sit comfortably, you
can close your eyes or not.
You can actually start
just by listening
to sound-- whether it's
the sound of my voice
or other sounds, which
are conveniently coming.
It's a way of
relaxing deep inside,
allowing your experience
to come and go.
And bring your attention to the
feeling of your body sitting,
whatever sensations
you discover.
Bring your attention
to your hands.
See if you can make
the shift from the more
conceptual level--
like, oh, fingers--
to the world of direct
sensation-- picking
up, pulsing, throbbing,
pressure, whatever it might be.
You don't have to name
these things, but feel them.
And bring your attention to the
feeling of your breath, just
the normal, natural
breath, wherever
you feel it most distinctly.
Maybe that's in the nostrils,
or the chest, or the abdomen.
When you find that place,
bring your attention there
and just rest.
See if you can feel one breath.
And if your attention
wanders, you
find yourself lost in thought,
spun out in a fantasy,
or you fall asleep,
don't worry about it.
This is the magic moment.
It's the next moment
after the distraction.
Listen to how you
speak to yourself.
How much anger is there?
How much compassion is there?
See if you can practice
gently letting go.
It's what one of
my teachers once
called exercising the letting-go
muscle-- gently letting go
and beginning again,
shepherding your attention back
to the feeling of the breath.
This is actually the
transformative training.
It's letting go, and with
compassion for yourself,
starting over.
So if you have to do that 10
billion times in the next five
minutes, that's totally fine.
Isn't that incredible?
That no matter what happens,
we can always begin again?
So right there,
that's the moment.
We say that the healing
is in the return,
not in never having
wandered to begin with.
That's resilience.
And when you feel ready,
you can open your eyes.
Do you have any
questions or comments,
anything you'd
like to talk about?
MALE SPEAKER: I'm going to
follow my own instructions.
So Sharon, thank you so much.
So you had that
comment earlier about
how lovingkindness is kind
of an embarrassing word.
So if you had the power
to just, like, rebrand it,
what would you use?
SHARON SALZBERG: Probably,
if I had the power
to totally rebrand it,
I'd say, connection.
The word in Pali, the language
of the original Buddhist text,
is metta-- M-E-T-T-A. And for
a while, at different times,
I had hoped that that word
might enter the culture,
as words sometimes do.
And it never happened.
And my most recent hope had been
when-- he was then an LA Laker
basketball player-- Ron Artest
changed his name to Metta World
Peace.
And I got really excited.
And then I guess last
season or the season
before, he behaved
badly on the court.
And my friends were sending
me these headlines, saying,
"Metta fails us,"
and things like that.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
He elbowed someone in the head.
SHARON SALZBERG: And
then he just changed
his name again, someone told me.
He changed it to something else.
So that's not going to happen.
I'd say connection, probably.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
So you were seeking practical
meditation forty years ago.
What can you tell
us about it now?
Because fine, I'll admit it.
Maybe I'm lazy.
I'm also looking for
practical meditation.
SHARON SALZBERG: OK.
I think practical
meditation's really good.
I see meditation practices
as skills training, really,
in three major arenas.
One is concentration,
or that kind
of gathering of our normally
scattered attention.
Mindfulness, which is
waking up to our experience
in a different way.
It's not having so
many filters intruding
on the way we perceive things.
One common filter is
projection into the future.
If something feels
uncomfortable right now, we
tend to start
thinking, what's it
going to feel like next week?
What's it going to
feel like next month?
Or dismissing certain things,
or having a big overlay.
I'm the only one who ever feels
this, something like that.
I should have been
able to stop this.
I shouldn't have this come up.
So mindfulness is a way
of uncluttering attention,
so that we have a cleaner,
clearer perception
of what's going on.
And then the third
great skill is
lovingkindness or
compassion, which
we practice in lots
of different ways.
So many methods will bring
these three together.
I think daily practice, or
close to daily practice,
is the most crucial element.
And by that, I mean a dedicated
period of 5, 10, 15, 20
minutes where you
are only seeking
to strengthen these qualities.
Because then it can
appear during your day.
So for example, we just
sat for 10 minutes.
And if you do that
for 10 minutes a day,
using something like the feeling
of the breath as your anchor
for your attention,
fortunately, the breath
goes to work with you.
Right?
It goes to the doctor's
office with you,
where you may have some anxiety.
Or it goes on your
commute with you.
And so it's a way of-- what
one of my very venerable
old meditation teachers called
the goal-- short moments
many times.
Short moments of awareness
many times a day.
Short moments of focus
And so if you're accustomed
to using something
like the feeling
of the breath, it's
very practical,
because then you could
be at work-- I always feel funny
when I say this at a workplace.
Let's say there's a
really contentious meeting
at some other workplace.
And tempers are
starting to flare,
and anxiety is
starting to go up.
You don't have to
open up a closet door,
and pull out all this equipment,
and sit down cross-legged,
and look funny.
You can be breathing.
And no one has to
know you're doing it.
You're resting your attention.
You're coming back
to yourself, you're
coming back to the moment.
You're cutting through the crazy
momentum going on around you
just by coming
back to the breath.
And so it's very private.
It's very personal.
And it's very practical.
So theoretically, you don't
have to take, say, that 5-, 10-,
20-minute period of just
devoting yourself to practice.
But I think that's
highly speculative
that we'll even remember.
One of the now classic
recommendations
is, don't pick up the
phone on the first ring.
Let it ring three
times and breathe,
and then you pick it up.
But how are we going
to remember that
in the middle of a kind
of chaotic or busy day?
I think if we've got those
building blocks in place,
we're more likely
to remember it.
And I did go into a
company somewhere,
and I made that recommendation.
And I looked up, and there
was panic on everyone's faces.
So I said, how about twice?
Just let the phone ring
twice-- two or three times.
You have to see what's
realistic for you.
But really, we can take
short moments many times,
if we remember to do that.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Sharon.
Thank you for
sharing your wisdom.
SHARON SALZBERG: Sure.
AUDIENCE: It's very funny.
As I was sitting up
there for meditation,
I was framing the questions
to ask you, and then you said,
let go.
If I sound incoherent,
please be compassionate.
I have two questions for you.
One is, do you have
any examples of leaders
in the corporate context
that embody the four values?
And if you could talk
a bit about that.
Because in my mind, they
seem a little orthogonal,
the leadership quotient and
the compassion quotient.
And the second question is, we
just did an annual performance
review that we all
have to fill out--
different attributes that
we rate our peers by--
and its execution, and
thought leadership,
and the traditional stuff.
It seems that if the
underlying drivers
for true, long-term,
sustainable performance
are those four qualities,
how do we bring awareness
to those in a more
structured way,
so that we can cultivate
them as individuals
and get supported
by the organization?
SHARON SALZBERG: Well, I
think in terms of the second,
there's a necessary place both
for empathy and for equanimity.
And it would be a
fantastic element, I think,
of a performance review.
Because ultimately, if we
talk about a kind of team,
or teamwork, some sensibility
like that, really, it's
both individual
excellence and the ability
to have that kind of resonance.
I mean, that's why
it's so interesting
that so many sports teams
are bringing in meditation
coaches-- including, apparently,
the Knicks because of Phil
Jackson, you know, and his
own interests, and his past
with the LA Lakers
and the Chicago Bulls.
So I think it's just fabulous.
But it's that same thing.
It's realizing that individual
excellence, and a premium
on that, does not
negate the need
for that sense of
communication, and resonance,
and being able to work together.
And so I think it would
be a fantastic element
to bring into a
performance review.
And in terms of a
leader, actually-- I'm
sure they exist in
the corporate world.
That's not the first
thought that I had.
And you could probably tell
me more than I would know.
But I actually thought
of different people
I know working in
different fields.
One-- I'm part of this
project through this place,
the Garrison
Institute, which is now
working with international
humanitarian aid workers,
and bringing tools like
yoga and meditation to that.
And I see the creative,
dynamic, phenomenal leaders
of those organizations
that are willing to support
in a very different way the
people who are going out there.
Because I think
the cultural norm--
and I've been told this
by different agency
heads and so on-- they're fine.
Or we can't spend any money
on "staff enrichment,"
is what they call it.
And the consequence of
that is that, you know,
these people are working in
incredible arenas of suffering
and trauma.
And there's tremendous
burnout and kind
of emotional consequences,
psychological consequences,
for a lot of people.
But there's a very
macho sort of norm,
plus probably some
fear about liability,
and admission of any kind
of vulnerability people
might be exposed to.
So to see what seems to me
the courage and creativity
of an agency saying, we have
to take care of our people.
This is not something frivolous
like staff enrichment.
This is something that-- the
mission isn't just external.
The mission is
internal, as well.
To have that kind
of uniform view--
I feel like I've seen
that in different places.
And I really admire it.
And so you can
tell me where that
exists in the corporate culture.
AUDIENCE: No, that's why
I asked the question.
SHARON SALZBERG: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SHARON SALZBERG: Thank you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I just want to echo
my thanks for you being here.
It's really an
honor to hear you.
And I did read your
book, "Real Happiness,"
which I think was the 28-day--
SHARON SALZBERG:
Yeah, challenge.
AUDIENCE: So in that
book, my recollection
is you have a different type
of meditation for each week.
And I'm curious, for somebody
who's beginning again
in meditation and who hasn't
had a regular practice,
do you think that
there's validity
in attempting the same type
of meditation every day,
like just focusing on
the breathing meditation?
Or does it matter?
Can you mix it up?
What are your real
recommendations
for somebody who
hasn't had the ability
to make meditation stick?
SHARON SALZBERG: Mm-hm.
I think you can mix it up.
But I think it's
probably worth doing
one technique for a while, just
so you feel confident in it.
And some of it depends
on your own mind.
Like, I have a very
distractable mind.
A lot of the stories
I tell about the kind
of crazy wandering mind are
true things I experience.
So I have the kind
of mind where,
once I learned more than one
technique, I would sit down,
I'd feel a few breaths,
and I'd think, well,
this isn't working.
Let me do some lovingkindness.
Then I'd do some lovingkindness
for two and a half seconds,
and then I'd think,
wow, that's boring.
You know?
Let me listen to sound.
And so I saw from
that that I did better
with some structure-- basically
saying, OK, for this week,
I'm going to basically try this,
unless something huge happens
that I feel the need to change.
And that helps me.
I had this conversation.
I saw Dan Harris
yesterday, coincidentally.
And he's been recommending
people sit five minutes a day.
And I said to him,
I understand that.
And I think in many
ways, that's good.
Especially if you
don't have longer,
it's absolutely worth doing
the five minutes a day.
But I said, you realize
that the first five minutes
are the hardest five minutes.
Because when we
sit down at home,
usually, the first
five minutes are just
this torrent of thoughts.
You know?
It's like, I forgot
to call so-and-so,
and what's that sound?
I think it's my refrigerator.
Oh, no, what if my
refrigerator's breaking?
Can you get a refrigerator
repair person anymore
in this world?
I don't know.
Maybe I need to get
a new refrigerator.
How do I do that?
Where am I going
to order it from?
Does Sears still exist?
You know?
Like.
[LAUGHTER]
SHARON SALZBERG: Right.
You know.
So it's just a lot of that.
And let's just say that
lasts five minutes,
and you sit for
only five minutes.
That's good, because that's
like a discharge of tension
and stress.
But you don't have a
chance to go deeper.
So if you've only
got five minutes,
I say, yes, do five minutes.
If you can do 10 or 15 or
20, it's that much better.
But it's the every
day-ness of it
that is the most
important thing.
OK, we need to stop.
Or you need to stop, anyway.
[LAUGHS] Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SHARON SALZBERG: Thank you.